I resent Matt Walsh because I think he's
a fascist I don't think about you at all
I wouldn't really call this an apology
and make no mistake Dylan Mulvaney is
our enemy he is an open visible active
and passionate Advocate or the abuse of
children the war on fundamental truth
the destruction of human society as we
know it no Dylan Mulvaney does not
advocate for child abuse and gender
affirming care isn't child abuse anyway
okay as it's been found that not
providing trans Healthcare to youth is
actually closer to a form of child abuse
band kids who are rejected utterly
totally baseless there are no credible
long-term studies that bear that out and
39 physical abuse that we can clearly
prove that trans people are not
committing child abuse but for the other
two claims I don't know what to do about
that they're so over the top and
dramatic war on Truth the downfall of
society how can you prove or disprove
that this is where I think Matt Walsh's
resentment has a little bit more to do
with Envy I mean I resent Matt Walsh
because I think he's a fascist you keep
using the horde I don't think it means
what you think it means but I do also
envy him I envy his status his platform
the fact that people might take him more
seriously than they'll take me
thank you but what if anything does Matt
wash Envy about queer people does he
Envy Dylan because she agreed to such
popularity so fast is he envious of the
fact that she got invited to things like
fashion shows different events that
she's met the president now we've
already dealt extensively with the claim
that gender transition decreases suicide
rates that part of what he said is
totally nonsense to the charge that I am
envious uh because Dylan Mulvaney gets
to go to fashion shows I don't know what
to say except that attending a fashion
show would be my actual hell as for
beating the president yes I admit that I
would be very eager for a chance to sit
across from the president with the
camera was rolling but for very
different reasons no I'm not envious of
Dylan Mulvaney I mean in order to elicit
Envy he would need to have something
that I want or embody some sort of trait
that I find admirable instead he has
none of the things I want out of life
and embodies everything that I want to
be the opposite of President Trump
recently issued a warning from his
Mar-A-Lago home quote our currency is
crashing will soon no longer be the
world standard which will be our
greatest defeat frankly in 200 years
there are three reasons the central
banks are dumping the US dollar
inflation deficit spending and our
insurmountable national debt the fact is
there is one asset that has withstood
famine Wars political and economic
upheaval dating all the way back to
Biblical times and that is gold I've
bought gold from Birch gold in
preparation for uncertain Economic Times
and you can trust them too you can now
own golden a tax sheltered retirement
account with the help of Birch gold
that's right Birch gold will help you
convert an existing Ira or 401K into an
IRA in Gold the best part is you don't
pay a penny out of pocket the current
currencies fail gold is a safe haven how
much more time does the Dollar have you
can protect your savings with gold Birch
gold has an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau they have
thousands of happy customers I'm one of
them if you want to be one of them you
can text Walsh to 989-898 to get your
free info kit on gold against Tex Walsh
to nine eight nine eight nine eight
today an unfortunate experience today
when I logged onto Facebook and I saw
this post by Matt Walsh I'll be honest
with you I thought it was satire I
thought Matt Walsh was either making a
joke or that he had been hacked but upon
further investigation
this was
the long day at work to a great full
wife and children who are glad to see
him and dinner cooking on the stove this
is literally all it takes to make a man
happy we are simple give us this and you
will have given us nearly everything we
need the only
in his entire post is where he says we
are simple you're right you guys are
simple-minded little
if your husband is unhappy consider
whether you have ever given him this one
thing he wants there's a good chance the
answer is no I was being abused in my
marriage and not to like to my own horn
I was a pretty good wife like I was the
wife who stayed fairly fit after two
C-sections I kept the house clean I did
the laundry I made the dinner the kids
were happy and well behaved on top of
all that I did all the fun little things
in the bedroom he wanted me to do I
would send him dirty pictures at work
and try to keep the spice alive I would
buy a new lingerie everything that you
can think of because I was taught like
this Matt Walsh post that if it failed
if the marriage failed if we weren't
happy if he wasn't happy it was on me
and he still abused me he still cheated
well I'm sorry you had that experience
in your marriage I am never should have
happened but you're making a mistake
that many people make these days of
assuming that a general principle is
wrong because of your own personal
experience so it's like if I said that
you should lock your doors at night and
use an alarm system to prevent break-ins
and you responded that my advice is bad
because you did that and still had a
break
does that mean that you shouldn't lock
your doors and use an alarm system if a
certain strategy isn't totally foolproof
does it automatically make it bad
what I'm recommending is that women
should be grateful and loving towards
their husbands that's it that's all I'm
saying now it's true that you could be
grateful and loving to your husband and
still end up in a terrible marriage
because he's a terrible person that can
happen terrible people exist in the
world and there are people who end up
married to terrible people it does
happen
but does that mean that wives shouldn't
be grateful and loving I mean are you
recommending in gratitude and resentment
is that a better strategy is that more
likely to produce positive marital
results
you can be faithful to your spouse and
still find that he is Unfaithful but
does that mean that we should tell
people to be unfaithful from the start
on the assumption that the others will
be too
of course not but maybe your point is
that we shouldn't put it all in the wife
we should tell the men to be grateful
and loving too well here's the good news
I never suggest otherwise in fact I
frequently encourage men to love their
wives and be faithful and good to them I
say that all the time I just didn't
happen to make that point in that
particular statement that you read there
are many points that I didn't make
because I was only making the point that
I did make I can't say everything every
time I say anything and that limitation
does not give you the right to invent a
whole series of opinions and statements
I never expressed
foreign
[Music]